[Music]
on this Monday night situation critical
at an Ontario nursing home nine people
died as the virus sweeps through a care
home our worst nightmare and possibly
beyond that came true plus an entire
community in Quebec now under quarantine
payroll plan new details on the massive
wage subsidy for businesses and
charities stranded and sick at sea where
will two cruise ships carrying Canadians
be allowed to dock staggering numbers in
New York as a makeshift hospital goes up
in Central Park we've been behind this
virus from day one can Canada avoid the
same crisis and ethical dilemma if there
are too many patients and too few
ventilators who gets treated first
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
nine weeks after the first confirmed
case of kovat 19 in Canada and this
country has reached a critical moment
now is the time we begin to find out how
much the physical distancing and self
isolation we're doing is slowing the
spread of the virus
there are signs in some places it is
beginning to work and tonight there's
another example of what happens when the
virus spreads through a care home nine
people connected to a long-term care
home and Bobcaygeon Ontario have died
that's according to the homes medical
director 24 staff have tested positive
it is the biggest outbreak in Ontario
care home residents and the staff they
rely on are among the most vulnerable
the facilities are often understaffed
people work in more than one home and if
you have personal protection equipment
Ontario has the most deaths in the
country now 33 and it has strict new
advice tonight for anyone over the age
of 70 or who has underlying health
conditions stay home and self isolate
that means don't leave the house at all
Abigail Beeman reports on the toll this
virus is taking on a small town care
home where all shedding tears hein Crest
nursing homes medical director describes
it as a war zone
she says nine people have died of
colvett 19 and at least 35 residents are
sick there's 65 beds in the home our
worst nightmare and possibly beyond that
came true residents family members like
Lindsey Blair's can only wait at home
hoping for the best we're putting an
iron ring of production around our
seniors especially those in long-term
care and retirement homes there's no
agency putting out information on care
homes no coordinated way to get a
picture of what's inside stories like
Pine Crest emerging through the media
the Ontario premiers iron ring is 243
million dollars to protect residents
through more screening and cleaning and
increased capacity the province saw its
biggest daily increase in cases overall
Doug Ford is now asking anyone
over seventy and those who are
immunocompromised to self isolate and
warns everyone else to physically
distance we're prepared to take further
action if we do not see the spread of
this virus slow down in the coming days
this is a really critical week in our
fight against the corona virus Ottawa
stressing what happens in the next few
weeks is so dependent on how people
behave today especially all those
returning snowbirds and vacationers
legally required to self isolate head
directly home do not stop for groceries
or other essential supplies pick up the
phone get online and order what you need
the Deputy Prime Minister acknowledges
all these things aren't easy seniors
trying to figure out online grocery
orders physical distancing people having
trouble reaching service canada by phone
but while Christie Freeland apologizes
for the system kinks she's very clear
that all these measures are quote what
we have to do abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa here are the big picture numbers
in Canada at least 74 hundred people
have now tested positive for kovat 19
across the country that's roughly 3% of
the 220,000 people who have been tested
so far it's not a complete picture of
how many are infected though because we
know not everyone with symptoms is
getting tested those who are confirmed
positive about 7 percent are in the
hospital 3 percent are in critical
condition and about 1 percent of people
who have tested positive have died about
half the confirmed cases in Canada are
in Quebec close to 600 new cases were
confirmed today alone and that brings
the total in Quebec to more than 3,400
there are clusters of outbreaks in
several regions and for the first time
in Canada an entire community has been
put into quarantine Mike Armstrong
reports an entire Hasidic community
north of Montreal is now officially
quarantined
aside from essential services no one is
allowed in or out about 3,500 people
have been ordered not to go anywhere
it's quite an intent veteran this may be
the most difficult decision in my life
ma'am you know about what we do now
health officials tested about 80 people
in the community
last week not even half the results are
back but they already have 15 positives
all people who recently traveled to the
US Travel is still an issue Quebec
police have set up roadblocks at main
entry points into the province telling
people to have to self isolate for two
weeks the province also has checkpoints
around some hot spots and is limiting
access to northern parts of Quebec
denser areas have been hit harder one
major clusters in Montreal's West End
people not from the area are being told
to stay away the local mayor says the
community skews older and is
predominantly Jewish to factors that
likely played a role in the outbreak
well it was expected because we have a
lot of snowbirds that returned to our
city in the last few weeks and we also
had a lot of celebrations
there isn't one specific reason klubecks
been so badly hit there are several
travel corridors are a factor there are
a lot of links to New York City but
another factor the premier points to is
the calendar most provinces hold spring
break in mid or late March and they were
canceled over kovat 19 well Quebec
Spring Break was the first week of March
families went on vacation not knowing
there was a threat in fact the week
after there were four days where
everyone went back to school and work
things didn't start shutting down until
the 13th we're facing a long and tough
battle Quebec Premier says the rate of
testing also boosts the numbers it's
testing 808 people per 100,000 residents
the average in the other provinces is
558 my carbs are Global News Montreal we
got more details today on the federal
plan to keep businesses afloat the wage
subsidy will be available to all
companies no matter how many employees
they have if they've had a 30% or more
drop in revenue because of the pandemic
the government will cover 75% of workers
wages on the first $58,000 of salary
which could mean payments of up to eight
hundred and forty seven dollars a week
the subsidy will be available to
eligible businesses nonprofit groups and
charities as well no matter how many
people they employ and the Prime
Minister had a stern warning for any
employers who might try to exploit the
wage subsidy
we are trusting you to do the right
thing if you have the means to pay the
remaining 25% that's not covered by the
subsidy please do so and if you think
this is a system you can take advantage
of or game don't there will be serious
consequences for those who do the wage
subsidy is massive nice nothing like it
has been done in Canada before and it's
been welcomed across the board from
business and political leaders no matter
their political stripe this pandemic is
testing our political leaders like never
before
today Ontario's premier Doug Ford made a
point of praising the federal response
especially the efforts of Deputy Prime
Minister Christian Freeland she's an
absolute champion you know I talk to her
every single day and any anything that
we need and vice versa we work very very
well together we're on the same team
we're on Team Canada this is how we're
gonna defeat and beat covet 19 by all
working together to cruise ships with
nearly 250 Canadians onboard are on
their way to Florida tonight after going
through the Panama Canal but it's not at
all clear where they'll be able to dock
on the Zaandam four people died and
nearly 200 others have flu-like symptoms
almost 800 passengers without symptoms
were transferred to the sister ship the
Rotterdam both ships have been turned
away by several Latin American countries
and today Florida's governor said he
wants the cruise ship company to
dispatch medical personnel to the
infected ship rather than make the
states scarce hospital beds available to
any passengers the situation in Florida
is bad but the epicenter of its us
outbreak is New York this Navy hospital
ship arrived in New York City Harbor
today it has 1,000 beds on board and
will be used as overflow for people who
are not infected with Kovac 19 but need
hospital care the comfort Navy ship also
has 12 operating rooms that could be up
and running within 24 hours there's a
desperate shortage of beds and equipment
and not just in New York Jackson
prosecco reports body
New York's hospitals are running out of
room for the living and the dead really
are in Brooklyn a forklift loaded bodies
into a refrigerated truck the hospital
morgue is filled to capacity in some
emergency rooms plastic sheets are used
to separate infected patients as doctors
and nurses struggle with a shortage of
protective equipment for themselves we
are seeing a lot of younger patients
that are coming through the door that
are sicker as well and that that is
surprising in a little scary in iconic
Central Park a field hospital is under
construction while at the Convention
Center thousands of temporary beds await
their first patients kovat 19 has killed
more than 250 people in New York State
in just 24 hours
there is no American who is immune to
this virus I don't care if you live in
Kansas I don't care if you live in Texas
New York is days away from running out
of ventilators Louisiana only has enough
to last for another week
America's public health officials now
warn that even the most optimistic
scenario is bleak if we do things
together
well almost perfectly we could get in
the range of a hundred thousand to two
hundred thousand fatalities experts say
the response has been far from perfect
it's not consistent it's not uniform
across the country and there are still a
lot of people who are not taking this
seriously in Florida where case numbers
have begun to surge the governor signed
an order urging people to stay home but
only in part of the state while Virginia
near a complete lockdown that won't
expire until mid-june if we don't do
everything we can now we're going to
look back to wonder how many more lives
we could have saved in the rush to get
medical supplies there's a new wrinkle
states find themselves bidding against
each other and the federal government
and private hospitals all with single
suppliers that's resulting in higher
prices at the worst possible time Donna
there's such a scarce resource right now
Jackson thank you there's more alarming
news out of Washington State tonight at
least 45 members of a choir have been
died
no swith koban 19 about 60 members of
the Skagit Valley choral group went to
rehearsal on March 6 three weeks later
the majority of those who were there
have tested positive and two people have
died there's been a lot of mixed
messaging about masks who should wear
them and how much they really protect
you Austria for example is making it
compulsory to wear them in supermarkets
Austrian grocery stores will start
handing out free masks at entrances
though they are not medical grade masks
the World Health Organization in Canada
is public health officers say wearing
masks in public to protect yourself is
not necessary you should be keeping your
physical distance from others and
washing your hands plus we need to be
careful not to waste masks they should
be saved for frontline responders who
have direct contact with sick people
also if you have any symptoms you have
no business being out in public mask or
no mask Prince Charles who tested
positive for kovat 19 is now out of
self-isolation the 71 year old had only
mild symptoms and spent seven days at
the Royal Family's Balmoral estate in
Scotland and the planned date for
Tokyo's delayed Summer Olympics has now
been revealed the opening ceremony is
now planned for July 23rd 2021 almost
exactly a year after the original date
the Paralympics will begin if this is
all over on August 24th the
life-and-death dilemma for doctors
coming up what happens if you have too
many patients and not enough ventilators
you
we know the doctors in places like Italy
and New York have had to make some
heartbreaking decisions about who lives
and who dies
it hasn't come to that in Canada but as
Heather Eurex West reports ethics
committees across the country are now
helping frontline workers prepare for
some difficult choices there is a reason
that ventilators are also referred to as
life-support critically ill patients
need them to survive and with covin 19
doctors are learning that the sooner
patients are put on ventilation the
better their chance for recovery as more
people have been entering hospital we
are seeing an increase in people going
into ICU and putting and being put on a
ventilator sooner rather than later
because that seems to improve the
outcomes for what happens if hospital
resources are overwhelmed and there are
simply not enough ventilators to go
around hospitals in Canada are now
preparing for those difficult decisions
that may come if what's happened in
Italy or New York were to happen here
trying to save as many lives as we can
as opposed to a particular life dr.
Timothy Christie is a medical ethicist
who is part of an ethics committee in
New Brunswick similar committees have
been struck across the country to help
guide physicians through the weeks ahead
the competition say where more than one
person needs a particular thing like
invasive mechanical ventilation in Italy
doctors consider a patient's age
pre-existing medical conditions even
whether they have family to help them
recover before deciding whether those
patients will get a coveted ICU spot in
some US states intellectual disabilities
are also considered I feel very strongly
on this professional point of view that
we cannot do this in Canadian society
instead ethicist Carrie Bowman believes
priorities should be based solely on
whether that patient is likely to
recover which may mean withdrawing life
support earlier from patients who just
aren't getting better that are not
progressing and the ventilator is needed
that is going to be profoundly tough
tough decisions that may be needed to
save the most lives as this virus
spreads Heather York's West Global News
Calgary
still ahead could what's happening in
New York happened in Canada's largest
city
we're all watching
what's happening in the United States
next door to us it's now the epicenter
of the global covin 19 pandemic and it's
hitting close to home for a lot of
Canadians in Toronto this country's
biggest city there are now nearly 600
cases that's still a fraction of what
New York City is dealing with but the
two cities are often compared as
financial and cultural hubs so is it
possible Toronto could be at the same
kind of risk
Jeff simple went to find out New York
City's health care workers have endured
hurricanes and 9/11 but say they've
never encountered a threat like this
we're fighting for your lives but we
also fighting for our lives too we are
also scared the epicenter of the u.s.
outbreak is watching its kovat 19 cases
soar and supplies run out I need I wear
and I need face masks any as many as you
can get it and for many Canadians these
scenes are hitting too close to home
this is right across the border and you
know sadly if it can happen there it can
happen anywhere but so far the outbreak
is unfolding much differently here in
part because it's easier to keep your
distance New York City averages more
than 10,000 people per square kilometer
that's twice as many as the city of
Toronto in fact Vancouver tops Canada's
list when it comes to population density
but is still nowhere close to the most
crowded community in the United States
Manhattan home to more than 25,000
people per square kilometer as the more
denser cities who have the more human
interaction you have the more people go
to the grocery stores meet in elevators
small places there's a lot more
entertainment options so that all these
factors enhance the spread and in New
York that problem is compounded by
healthcare accessibility and poverty but
population density doesn't necessarily
determine destiny
soeul is twice as crowded as New York
but South Korea has had far more success
curtailing the contagion in part experts
say because they tested early and often
and so too did Canada we had a better
ability to test people wasn't perfect
but it was better than what was
happening in many parts of the state and
the result is plain to see the number of
confirmed cases in Ontario compared to
New York State but experts warn our
actions this week could make the
difference it really is up to us whether
or not we want to take the path of New
York City just simple Global News
Toronto next how where you live affects
how physically distant you can be
keeping physically distant isn't how
most humans are wired were social beings
by nature now we're all being forced
into this weird but essential new
reality staying apart but trying to
stick together as Eric Sorenson reports
where you live can make a big difference
for just a moment here and there it
looks normal but then you realize most
people close together our partners or
family a household bubble out for a walk
we're pretty much separating or the
household is separated from everyone
else and everyone else is increasingly
keeping their distance Mary Joe Anderson
stays near her husband and that's it
you're definitely able to to distance
yourself when you're walking I noticed
even for this interviewer a very distant
physical distance is the new reality but
from above you see it's experience
differently in rural Canada working at
home seeing only family can be a normal
day and where people have homes close
together even then there is space and
backyards the biggest adjustment may be
downtown living where thousands of
people are stacked on top of one another
think about elevators you have to be
very careful about so you know press the
button like with your elbow in a
30-story building you can't help but
converge on strangers sometimes and I
just look at people and I'm like you're
a hotbed of germs so I'm gonna keep my
distance
there is something unnerving being in a
big city and not bumping into people
amidst the glass and concrete canyons
the usual attractions from theatres to
big league sports all the reasons to
cluster downtown have vanished why did I
choose to live in a city because I love
the people I missed that the Ripley is
an Ag oh and all of the great parts that
make this city wonderful have to
close down it's hard for us social
beings it's hard right there is some
advantage in big towns or small when
where you live has space Lisa Forte with
her dog grace sees that we're fortunate
we're in a home in a small cul-de-sac so
we have a small yard but it still is
large enough for her to go out and for
me to sit outside and putter around a
little bit still it's an adjustment for
everyone so it's chin up downtown we're
all adjusting to it at the same time we
are very much in this together and
there's a small comfort and hope and
doing that and apart from your tight
circle keep your distance
wherever you are we're not walking
arm-in-arm any longer no just
emotionally we walk arm-in-arm
physically we keep a little distance
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Donna Friesen we want to thank all
of you again who have to go out to work
the essential workers and everything
from hospitals to grocery stores we
couldn't survive without you and finally
we know people were panic buying toilet
paper now it's puzzles apparently
they're being snapped up online so much
so there's a shortage of them looks like
lots of people are puzzling their way
through this pandemic thanks for
watching and take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you